so so what are the circumstances keeping
north korea as it is certainly there's
external pressure for them to change
their ways
open up free their people but my
understanding is like china is very
defensive
china likes north korea as sort of like
this problem that the rest of the world
needs to come to china
to work on
uh they're a crazy guy with the nukes
and only we can negotiate like if you
have to talk to us and
it actually ties a lot into um sort of
china's internal political struggles as
well because certain factions within
china were the ones
working with the kim family
other factions
did not
uh so yeah it's it's
it's leverage for them yeah it's
leverage and it definitely makes china
look better
it really does
yeah well like hearing a story where you
say that that that you felt being a
slave in china was better because at
least you had food
but the thing is what shocks me is in
america like these people talking about
slavery that happened hundreds of years
ago right this is happening right now
when you're sitting down do you know
during the recovery time if you go to
buy to the chinese google you can north
korean girls for nine hundred dollars
you order them in
and this is happening and nobody in
mainstream like michelle obama has no
problem standing up for girls are
captured by isis or boko haram
where is any public figure in the
mainstream standing up for this girls
right now there are 300 000 north korean
refugees in china hiding and most of
them are women and most of them are
trafficked so we have actual modern day
slaves existing china has a huge human
trafficking problem yeah because the one
child policy screwed up the third
population
30 million more men men cannot find
wives so where do these women being
bought by these 30 million men who
cannot afford wives in china wow are
there organizations that buy the women
to then free them and get them to other
countries we do that i work with a lot
of non-profits we do rescue work but
it's become so hard on the covet
so but the thing is it's you know now in
america right now there is only over 200
north koreans made it to america for
during the last 75 years
yikes yeah
for for you to come from south korea to
the united states was it difficult
i came as a south korean
so oh so you walked right in yeah but
then i had to get a visa i mean i came
legally yeah all right like
as a south korean you can just fly here
on like without notice and get visa on
entry right you get the electronic visa
but it's hard to get a working permit
right you can come as a tourist but it's
very hard to come as immigrate immigrant
from south korea yeah yeah it's actually
fairly difficult i think for anybody to
to to get a work visa in the united
states i say relatively difficult but
i'm sure there's a lot of countries
where it's a lot harder especially with
like middle eastern refugees into europe
i've seen a lot of those stories
yeah so it's pretty closed off yeah yeah
yeah you know i've heard people say that
japan is an ethno state and i've heard
other people say it's not but i'm
curious you know what you guys think
about that i'm not an expert on japan
outside of anime
[Laughter]
well so
i guess the difficult thing is i'd like
to try and predict the future you know
i'd like to know can we can we take we
we've made some of these statements like
oh we can see what happened in north
korea we can see how people behave how
they're scared to speak and then
we we we've said somehow north korea
became this way
but is it really like the u.s could
track in a similar direction or is it is
it just
fanciful thinking that the us would ever
become like this you know
is the u.s going to break out of this
and just become sane again and defeat
the the cultural marxist ideology i'm
fairly optimistic to be completely
honest i mean i i see these parents
waking up i see
a lot of a lot of reason to be
optimistic in terms of what's happening
politically with people being snapped to
attention because of what's happening
and i have to imagine that there's
elements within the us government
they know everything we're saying and
they're worried about these things too
or
is the ideological split so severe that
these you know cultural marxist and
critical race theorists control too much
well i think with everything happening
in schools that's
that was definitely overreach like once
you start targeting people's kids that's
when people really freak out that brings
it to home
so i think this is
like all the debate about critical race
theory i think it's really a good window
of opportunity to educate people about
what marxist ideology is how it
functions how it takes an issue and
inverts it and then flips it into
something else like for example race
uh you know decades ago
we as a country made a decision that you
know judging people by the color of
their skin is wrong that's racist and
now it's it's flipped so it's like oh no
no you should develop racial
consciousness i think is the term they
use you need to be able to look at
people by race so you can properly sort
them out based on their privilege and
their
oppressor status
that's creepy it is it's it's kind of
the opposite of taoism actually
yeah
i'm curious about war
um we recently saw china send the most
warships they've ever warped warplanes
into the taiwanese defense zone
and so there's this
obviously one thing we mentioned often
is through city strap there's a very
real fear that war will be happening
soon
i'm wondering before we start talking
about china though
this stuff that you see with north korea
with the firing of the nuclear missiles
do you feel there's anything to that or
is it just kim jong-un says look at me
i'm a nuisance give me free stuff and
there's not actually going to be any
real conflict out of the nuclear weapons
in north korea
i think kim jong is very rational enough
not to start a war with any country he
knows when he does that he's gonna be
done right i'm not gonna get him so i
don't think that can ever happen but
it it just i think kim jong-un's uh goal
is waiting for the west to be weakened
right
for the west to be destabilized right
now there's so much internal problem
america is so busy with themselves right
now not able to solve any problems like
globally yeah so it's a good thing for
himself right he wants to beat america
and internally he just keep building
capability with the missiles so someday
his dream might get that he might bomb
america entirely
and i mean he's his bombs can reach
hawaii dc i mean but you know bombing
few cities not gonna he's not gonna win
the war right he can attack damage the
usa but not gonna win but when america
is so busy he just keep doing this his
thing if if he were to try and fire a
nuke or something would china china
would stop them right
uh china would be probably forced in
position where would have to at least
offer some kind of lip service about
like that's bad yeah because they don't
want the
rest of the world to turn against china
right because like if if you if you are
a country backing north korea nuking
some other country that's that's bad pr
yeah
um practically speaking what they would
do i
china is worried about north korea
becoming
a little
too hot to handle too unwilling to
listen to beijing leadership
as i recall kim jong-un didn't even meet
with xi jinping for many years until
until yeah trump was about to meet with
him and then suddenly like the two sides
it wasn't kim jong-un didn't want it xi
jinping didn't invite him do you know
that don't take the uncle
he was a chinese guy he was funded by
china a lot the uncle who got executed
right oh yeah so when
kim jong-un killed his uncle china got
so upset because they just did it
independently
so xi jimmy didn't invite him didn't
like accept as allergic to minor king
leader but when he wants to meet trump
because china had like jumped before
didn't wasn't the brother that kim
jong-un poisoned also
like hiding in china he was kind of
being supported by china
china has been trying to push like their
own interest in north korea by pushing
people who would make the kind of market
reforms yeah they want and supposedly
kim jong-nam kim jong-nam was open he
was open to that idea
so china always recommended north korea
to take our path your comments probably
gonna last forever and it's like open up
a little so people don't die from
starvation right like what's the point
of all this and those are like no no no
we are fine so kim jong un get rid of
any reformers in the internal land
china wants
north korea to to do better and adopt
some more of their kind of policies
exactly they won they they toured kim
jong-un the second game when he was
alive showed him around look at us what
we have done like luke is beijing like
two weeks tour show him like take the
reform like path
and then kim jong-un goes back nope nope
we're gonna hit that right this might be
a dark question but why isn't anybody
just removed that lineage just gotten
rid of that family
i mean certainly there are people you
mentioned they're hiding out in china
even china's got interest in this
does no one want to i mean look people
have tried to
remove castro saddam hussein
the issue is china does not want a wave
of north korean refugees flooding into
china
interesting they don't want to be
responsible for north korea because it's
so
terrible right now like you have to
rebuild the society and they scratch
right and they can't let the us take it
yeah because if they don't the us walks
right in and they don't want the us on
their border yup
it's their buffer yeah so complicated
and so horrifying because there are
people here who need
food and resources and just more
importantly opportunity i mean it sounds
like if you got rid of the
authoritarianism these people would just
thrive yeah do you know like north
koreans as a nation one of the highest
iqs in the world no one the way they
build these nukes and you north korea's
only country can bully buy them right
byron's been trying to reach out to kim
jong-un
anytime anywhere without putting any
concessions i want to meet you and talk
to you kim jong-un will not return his
course since february but but trump
yeah trump was tough guy kim jong-un
knew that he could not bully trump so
whatever he was sending the love letters
to trump right please him and byron like
kim jong knows like i can bully you
whatever way i want to well i love it
when kim jong-un called uh trump a
daughtered
you know
your daughter a daughter
like searched the world
yeah yeah old fumbling certainly that
that works for joe biden yeah but then
trump was like i would never call him
short and fat
wow that was our president
so but how do you feel about you know uh
i'll tell you this there are a lot of
people who are in this country don't
like trump
and like clockwork they were all
extremely critical of trump for meeting
with kim jong-un and cross and and just
meeting him in general i looked at that
when trump crossed the dmz into north
korea with no security i thought that
was tremendous but what's what's your
thought
back then i was more like seeing black
and white like you don't just sit down
with the modern day hitler and then
treating him like modern like actual
leader of the country like north korean
people didn't choose kim jong-un to
represent us he's a dictator right so
the fact that trump was going there
without actually any concessions from
like kim jong-un was already lost he
didn't get anything back instead kim
jong-un did a huge promotion at home
showing like look at me now even though
america is backing me so if there's any
internal credit that would happen they
don't want to go after a guy that is
accepting as a legitimate leader so
internally it was so bad however now
like in a way
biting is worse right like i mean trump
at least brought a highlight to the
issue
and tried to serve something about it
like by then recently they review their
policy towards north korea
which is going to be exactly what obama
did strategic patience which is a
strategically you do not think just
waiting and kim jong-un moved take the
first positive move
so they if they ignore north korea like
this for five years and eight years
later we don't know what north korea
ends up with the nuclear like capability
yeah yeah i i certainly see what you're
saying with trump i was uh i was hopeful
that
you know trump without security
crossed into north korea and they could
have just snatched him up they had you
know obviously
they wouldn't because there's you can't
take the american president but it felt
like at least this was some
normalization some yeah but but i
certainly see what you're saying i was
hoping that it was a first step towards
trust
and maybe some kind of normalized trade
maybe some kind of encouragement towards
you know look there's opportunity if you
if you change some of the your ways but
you know based on what what you've all
been saying about how china wants the
reform and they don't it really does
feel like th this the the kim il family
is a bunch of despotic
what's the what's the megalomaniacs
who think they're god yeah they're so
paranoid and also the thing is i mean if
we are negotiating with north korea for
the first time makes sense to
honor them make them feel comfortable
and trusted this guy has been playing
the same playbook for like not 70
something years
they know what they know
what they want to so in a way it just
doesn't work anymore like talking to
north korea and then just try to make
them warm and come out it's not gonna
work it's gonna take way more than to
change north korea when you live there
did you ever encounter south korean
propaganda
in north korea yeah every single day
like i did not know south korea was
independent country they told us that
eurus is colonizing them it's a modern
day colonization and then how these
children get raped by your soldiers
and entirely like cartoons filled with
the most corrupt and then how entire
humanity wanna come to north korea
yeah entire humanity there's a song in
north dakota nothing to envy
it's a song because we have nothing done
we live in a socialist paradise you
literally have nothing
you know um
when i interviewed these these uh new
zealanders who rode their motorcycles
through new zealand i'm through north
korea the one thing they did say was
like
beautiful country
untainted
nature
no no no there's no trash no trash but
that's not true you think so right you
don't think so
look at just the why north korea is
intact every year they have flooding
massive flooding
so we don't have it as electricity north
korea is very cold we are like 80
mountains a country so people need to
get us dominant to burn cook food we
live in like 16th century time we go to
river to bath we i never seen a shower
like never seen anything we go to a few
times a year we go to river and take a
bath and that's it so we have to get a
chop the woods to fly start a fire so
people go into the mountains and cut
down entire trees and the big trees
china took it china took it and then the
coal mining so
china owned north korea now
they lent this like mines coal mines
gold mines for 100 years at least 200
years late so they're digging digging
digging pollution and the nuclear the
debris they're doing so much test that
now people north korea got deformed in
their like
dna changes
so so much flooding i mean they're i'm
sure they've gone to the part where
there are trees there yeah but when
normal people live we don't get the
trees we don't get nature i'm so shocked
when i was here today seeing all these
trees like so many trees
oh you're in chicago now too yeah yeah i
think a lot of people uh might not know
this i didn't even i grew up in chicago
when you fly in
chicago is like a forest because every
city street has just a tree in front of
every house
you go to new york and it's there's
trees but it's a big concrete block and
la's the same way
yeah trees everywhere yeah that's that's
that that really is something truly
amazing about chicago that i i should
definitely give a credit for
a lot of cities but to have
every city street with trees lining
every house it really is it really is
fantastic yeah
so i i i'm pretty sure
the people that i interviewed
they said that they chose their route
but i'm sure it was just that it was an
acceptable route in the first place of
course because if they went through
bad areas
it was interesting he said
they told me that
a lot of people criticize north korea
for their potemkin villages when when
someone comes in to interview they bring
them and they show this wonderful
supermarket and they say look at all the
glorious bounty
and we in the u.s we say they're putting
on a show to make it seem like they're
successful
what this uh this new zealander told me
was no no they're just dressing up like
like when you have your friends over you
wear your sunday's best you're not
trying to lie to them you're trying to
be presentable right
that that was their perspective on it my
perspective is they're trying to trick
you into thinking that people aren't
suffering and dying in the streets
soviet union did that worked on a lot of
u.s officials bernie sanders
who who was it who said that uh they
they came to the u.s and said if if my
people saw what you know uh we've done
to them because he was like at a
supermarket it was a cuban guy was it a
cuban yeah it was a cuban guy who said
you know he was at an aldi
right so it's not even like it was not
like you know whole foods he's got an
aldi isn't that not an american chain
it's german
yeah
so
like he was yeah he was just saying like
he was standing in an aldi and then he
got too depressed and had to leave
because he was like they've destroyed
our people yeah they've destroyed our
country like yeah i thought that was a
russian guy who said that you know if if
the people if my people saw
the you know the variety or whatever
of the americans there would be a
revolution overnight or something like
that that sounds familiar i can't place
it though i do think there's something
silly about having like 80 different
kinds of peanut butter
but i suppose i'll take 80 kinds of
peanut butter over no peanut butter at
all the market will decide
all one kind of peanut butter yeah right
right right
kim jong-un brand peanut butter
different flavors here's one with the
red label there's one with the yellow
label
yeah the joke is that in um
in communist countries you wait in a red
line in capitalist countries the bride
line forms for you or something like
that yeah the bride is in the line
waiting for you all just on the shelf
and everything like that i mean we we
have our problems though
i think that
if you go back to the early 1900s
the rise of the communists and the
fascist factions in in in europe
and uh you know more so towards world
war ii
the communists get defeated in europe by
the fascists the fascists get defeated
by the allies and the soviet union but
then communism begins to flourish unless
we get the cold war for several decades
i think one of the challenges we face is
that
individual liberty
has weaknesses
we tolerate
these authoritarians these communists
and they exploit yeah and so sure we had
a cold war
we won the cold war but i don't think
the cold war is actually over sure the
soviet union collapsed because their
ideology doesn't work their plans make
no sense they have to kill people to
support it but so long as there are
zealots
who are willing to lie cheat and steal
to give what they want
we we potentially walk the path towards
that corruption as well certainly you
know countries became the way they were
it's going to require everybody to be
constantly paying attention and fighting
back otherwise we we end up you know
like those countries
well ideological subversion is a huge
part of
communist tactics uh
chinese communist party does it all the
time they learn from the soviet union
and enhance things there's hardly a
u.s official who hasn't at some point
been offered a trip to china
or
money chinese money gets into all kinds
of places
and
and that's just we're talking about the
chinese communist party
the reality is that there are many
different factions to this broad concept
of communism
it's really a post-modern thing because
it does it kind of
defies
being pinned down to a definition
so
i mean like you you i've spoken to
people who are declared communists who
are like oh i hate what's happening in
china that's awful they don't see the
connections between themselves i do
think there's some kind of blindness
in the us about ideology on the left
where there's this kind of idea that
like there's no such thing as left
authoritarianism
where like we just pretend not to see it
or like the official media or whatever
pretend that there's no such thing as
left authoritarianism
you know
it's it's like a weird thing and it it
bleeds into like it happened with antifa
where people were like oh it's it's not
it's an idea not an organization but
then it also bleeds into like the china
stuff where you have people who are just
like well no china's not authoritarian
you know yeah well also importantly like
you had the trump administration
particularly pompeo bringing up ideology
this is an ideological struggle with
china that is something that the binding
administration is incapable of
discussing it can only can be competing
powers but the ideology which is
critical to this is completely off the
table i think one of the
most clever things pulled off by the
communist or marxist or authoritarian
left is that they call themselves
libertarian left and we see this
expressed in memes
so there's the political compass memes
which i'm sure you you've seen the
political comments
yeah are you familiar with the political
compass it's it's it's a square and
there's four quadrants and then you have
the top left which is authoritarian the
top right which is authoritarian and the
bottom you know you have left and right
that are libertarian
so the libertarian rights easily
definable they're free market
capitalists you know they're like you
can sell whatever you want to whoever
you want as long as you agree to it
buyer beware
uh caveat emptor i think it's a that's
how you say it and then you have the
authoritarian right which tends to be
ideologically driven command economies
ultra traditionalist and then you have
the authoritarian left which is the
tankies the soviet union etc but
whenever you look at the memes about the
libertarian left
its antifa
and its wokeness to authoritarian
ideologies so these people i think they
do it on purpose it's very clever
you tell someone that if you want to be
the freedom loving libertarian leftist
the good guys you have to beat people
you have to start fires and believe in
our you know occult ideology
in reality
if you look at the core of a libertarian
system with cooperative economics
it is small tribes it is small farms
working together it is that's it you
don't force anyone to do anything you
don't beat them in a submission you
don't demand they adhere to an ideology
but if if our if our jokes if our whole
perspective in society is that
freedom loving leftists are the people
burning down buildings and
and canceling people and threatening
them and destroying their lives
there literally is no libertarian left
in the united states so then what's the
opposition what you know what what what
opposes the authoritarians not the right
the right of the bad guys
well that leaves you with only the right
because there is no opposition from the
left they have abandoned their
principles they are trying to fit in
they are trying to look good wokeness is
nothing if not the appearance of looking
compassionate and friendly it's nothing
if not the appearance of saying oh we'll
save you we'll bring in all these
immigrants and do all this stuff it
sounds great so there's no pushback on
it and there absolutely should be it's
put us in this position yeah it's it's
the tricky thing about marxism or
communism whatever you want to call this
ideology is that it really takes
advantage of the fact that i think most
people are good people they want to help
people they would like to see the world
be a more equal better place yeah but
marx presented this extremely simplistic
view of all of human society there are
only the oppressors
and the oppressed anything you do as an
individual
doesn't matter you are either in the
oppressed or the oppressors to create a
better world
obviously you need to get rid of the
oppressors
they're not going to want to be
kicked out therefore you have to kick
them out yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time